(whooshing)
- [Announcer] This
program is a presentation
of UCTV for educational
and noncommercial use only.
(bright music)
- Welcome to the second of the
Hitchcock Lecture series.
I'm Fenyong Liu,
a professor from School of Public Health
and also the chair of the Graduate Group
of Comparative Biochemistry.
On behalf of the Dean of
the Graduate Division,
as well as the Hitchcock
Selection Committee,
it's my great pleasure,
as well as my honor,
to introduce today's speaker,
Professor Sidney Altman.
Professor Altman is truly
a distinguished scientist
and an outstanding teacher.
More importantly, he's
also a wonderful mentor
as I personally experienced
as a postdoc fellow
in his laboratory at Yale.
I will not repeat the long
list of his accomplishments
here as Professor Lester did yesterday.
However, I would only want to edit that
he has spent his entire
40-plus year career
focused on a single, yet
critically important enzyme
called Ribonuclease P or RNAse P.
His scientific journey on RNAse P
is an inspiring story.
It starts with his initial discovery
of the substrate, as well
as the enzymatic activity
of the enzyme RNAse P
when he was a postdoc fellow
under the guidance of Sydney
Brenner and Francis Crick
at MRC Laboratory of Molecular Biology
in Cambridge, England.
He then moved to Yale,
subsequently cloning the RNA subunit
of the enzyme, RNAse P
and demonstrating the catalytic activity
of the RNA subunit.
His research has revolutionized
the field of molecular biology
specifically the function
of RNA molecules.
Today he will give us
his personal reflection
of the discovery of the catalytic RNA
and share with us his
recent research progress
in his laboratory.
Please join me in
welcoming Professor Altman.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much, Fenyong
for the introduction and for
your wonderful hospitality
during my visit here.
And once again, I wanna thank the members
of the Hitchcock
Committee for selecting me
for these lectures,
and I hope I deliver
in some reasonable way.
I want to start by
repeating something I said
at the beginning of yesterday's lecture
which is that you've
all paid for my research
over the past 30 or 40 years.
Your income tax of which a few pennies
on a dollar, so to speak,
are devoted to my particular research
through the National Institutes of Health
and the National Science Foundation.
And I want to thank all of you taxpayers
for your donations over the years.
I feel that's a way of indicating my
appreciation instead of showing a slide
with many different names and
many different agencies on it.
Okay, so yesterday we talked about
the origin of life a little bit
and what the RNA world was.
And today I'm gonna
focus on ribonuclease P
which Fenyong indicated
which has a subunit that is catalytic.
What I'm going to do is talk about
both the RNA and the
protein subunits of RNAse P
in various organisms,
and I wanna indicate that RNAse P
is an essential enzyme in all organisms.
I won't go through the data,
but it is clear that without RNAse P
these organisms don't grow.
After I talk a little bit about the enzyme
I'm going to talk about
different substrates
both in E. coli and in higher organisms.
And then the last part
of my lecture will be on
some recent experiments in my lab
in which RNase P is an important mechanism
in providing a drug therapy.
The first slide you see
is an old slide and it indicates
the first substrate for RNase P.
This is a tRNA molecule
as I showed you yesterday.
It's in two dimensions.
And these are extra
nucleotides at one side of it.
And RNase P cuts right
here at nucleotide one
of the mature tRNA sequence.
So all these nucleotides are removed.
These nucleotides are
extra nucleotides too
and they're removed by different enzymes.
So essentially we make
virtually a functional tRNA
out of this cleavage here.
One of the problems we had to confront
and I think we solved it
as I'll show you later
is what is the specificity of this enzyme?
In fact there are about 60 different
tRNA precursors in every cell.
None of them have a,
none of them have a consensus sequence
or similar sequences
around the cleavage site.
And so how does this enzyme
recognize its substrate?
It does recognize it by looking at
a partial RNA helix on
this side of the substrate
and a single-stranded
region on this side here.
We have two extra base pairs here,
but it's not at all clear
that they form in vivo
under the conditions
that we're talking about.
Now this is a chart which characterizes
the catalytic activity of
the RNA subunit of RNase P.
Let me just say although
you cannot see it clearly,
it's not shown here,
the structure of the catalytic subunit,
although I will show a picture of that
as it has been recently crystallized
by Mondragon at Northwestern University,
the catalytic structure
is extremely similar
in all organisms.
However there is one
difference between that
and the proteins in the enzyme.
In E. coli bacteria,
let's say in E. coli and
in bacteria generally,
there's one RNA subunit which is catalytic
and there's one very
small protein subunit.
If we can rate the catalytic
activity in bacteria,
let's say it's of the
order of one to 10 here.
Then we have other species
involve the Archaea
which we now classify as
a separate kingdom here,
and the Eukarya or eukaryotes.
In Archaea there's one RNA subunit
and four and possibly
some cases more proteins
in the enzyme.
The RNA subunit is catalytic
and in several cases tested.
But the catalytic activity
is only about 1/10 to 1/100
of that compared to that in E. coli,
but it's easily recognizable.
And this is at pH six
where in fact there's very
little degradation of the RNA
as you incubate it in a reaction mixture
so that you can run
reaction times over night
at pH six under the conditions
Leif Kirsebom in Sweden really devised.
And you can easily see very
low amounts of activity.
And Kirsebom and his group found that the
RNA from a couple of Eukarya,
as there's one RNA subunit
and there are nine or
more protein subunits.
The catalytic activity here
is about 10 to the minus five
compared to the catalytic activity here.
So these are
measurements that have
been made rather carefully,
so we're very confident of these numbers.
This indicates the uncatalyzed reaction.
So if you just let the
substrate sit around,
you'll find the cleavage rate is around
10 to the minus nine or so.
And here are the relative references:
Guerrier-Takada et al. in E. coli,
Pannuci et al. in at
least one of the Archaea,
and Kikovska and Kirsebom
et al. on eukaryotes.
I think that's all I'm
gonna say about the RNA
at the moment.
Now we're gonna talk about diversity
in the subunit composition of RNAse P.
So we have in bacteria
one protein which we call,
we had labeled a long time ago C5 protein
because it just of its position in gels.
In Archaea there are
four different proteins,
and now another one has been characterized
which is actually a ribosomal subunit
which when added to these four
stimulates the activity considerably.
And it has some homology
with one of the proteins found in yeast
and in HeLa cells.
And we have in HeLa cells,
this is a human enzyme,
10 subunits here and you can see
some of them have homology
to the Archaea subunits.
Here's RPP30.
Here, RPP38.
Here et cetera, RPP21 and 29
and POP5 here.
But there's several subunits here
and as I indicated from
the previous slide,
they appear to contribute
to the catalytic activity.
And by saying appear to contribute,
it could very well mean stimulating
the RNA activity by itself
by adding these various proteins.
So I should also say something about
the evolution of the RNA subunit.
The shape as you can draw
in at least two dimensions
is very similar from
bacteria up to human cells.
There are some differences,
generally it's about,
the RNA's about 350 nucleotides in size.
But there are a couple of yeasts
where it's 250 nucleotides in size
and there are a couple of other organisms
where it's like 800 or
900 nucleotides in size.
However the difference in size
corresponds to a difference
in the recognition
of certain subunits,
and does not seem to affect
generally what we observe.
The catalytic portion of the enzyme
remains more or less constant
although it does change somewhat
between the Eukarya and bacteria.
And,
these slides are from Venkat Gopalan
at Ohio State University.
And this gives an
indication of the evolution
of the protein subunits.
We have a common ancestor here
where presumably RNase P
lacked protein subunits.
Although there's no direct evidence,
there's nothing to indicate that that
should not be the case,
we know that if we isolate
the RNA subunit by itself
in test tubes, in vitro,
it has the catalytic
activity that is for bacteria
and we can show it for
these other organisms.
And then
for bacteria there's the origin
of a single protein cofactor.
And for the other organisms here
apparently you start sharing
four protein subunits,
and then you have the Archaea.
And the Eukarya are out here.
So this is a rough picture of
the evolution of this enzyme
in terms, if I may make the reference
to what I talked about yesterday,
this is an indication of
the complexity of evolution
as it goes along.
So let's not think about humans
as thinking individuals for a moment,
but if we just look the structure
of a key enzyme, in this case,
and determine what goes on,
the bacterias are very simple,
but eukaroytes are quite complicated
in this particular case.
And we see that the proteins
seem to have replaced
the contribution of RNA in
terms of the catalytic activity.
Now I'm gonna talk about some substrates
that have been found in E. coli to date,
and some of them exist in
other bacteria as well.
First, we have tRNA precursors
which are listed here
and as I said there are
about 60 different precursors
in any particular organism,
bacteria or eukaryotes.
Then we have
4.5 sRNA in which the structure
can be drawn like this
of long double-stranded regions,
a long hairpin.
But the precursor has
extra nucleotides here
and the arrow indicates
where E. coli will cleave it
just at this point here.
So this in fact
was good reason to believe
that our other data
on the structural
features that are required
for cleavage by RNase P is correct.
That is to say, we have a long period
of double-stranded RNA here
of which actually you
only need about a half a
helical strand of,
a helical twist of RNA,
and a single-stranded region here.
This is another similar
substrate from E. coli.
Here are others, I won't go into what
they're doing at the moment.
This is a phage RNA actually.
This is actually tmRNA
or an RNA which is both a messenger RNA
and looks like a tRNA.
That is to say, there's a coding region
in this region here and it codes for a
small protein of about 11 amino acids
which tags proteins
that are to be degraded
inside E. coli and other organisms.
But the ends of the molecule
look just like a tRNA molecule
and it has a precursor sequence here,
and RNA cleaves it right here.
So these are all important
molecules in E. coli,
and they have,
they are not unstable molecules.
They have reasonable
lifetimes inside cells.
And if you know how to look for them,
and now we know how to look for these,
you can find them quite easily.
Several years ago,
about seven or eight years ago,
in my lab it was found that there was
another set of substrates for RNase P.
And it remains to be shown by
really rigorous experiments
that this does function
in gene regulation.
But we've shown in
model systems that does.
So here are various operons indicated.
An operon is a region that has three genes
usually coding for similar
metabolic function,
but not always.
Here's another one here with five genes.
Here's the histidine
operon with several genes.
And the fat arrows are
coding regions for proteins.
And these narrow lines here
are the regions between proteins.
What we can say, for example,
is that RNase P, in these cases,
cleaves in the regions
between the coding regions.
So these underlines
indicate cleavage here.
One here.
One here,
and one in this region right here.
We isolated these
molecules just by looking
at a temperature-sensitive mutant
in RNase P at a high temperature
and we picked these molecules
out from many molecules
that you could find under these conditions
that did not appear under
normal growth conditions.
So these are some examples
of cleavage in our operon,
but it's much easier to
do things in an operon
that you really recognize
which is the lac operon
for the metabolism of lactose.
And here we have the lac operon.
There are three genes: lacZ, lacY, lacA.
We know what each one of these codes for,
and here are the intergenic
regions right here.
So here's the end of the lacY region
in this particular case.
So we're looking at this region in here.
And this is the beginning
of the lacA operon in UUG.
This is a UUA here.
And this is what the region between
the two coding proteins looks like.
And it looks like it
actually has a structure
that would be recognized by RNAse P.
And in fact it does.
This where P cleaves, it's right here.
I won't go into data,
but this just indicates
what I'm talking about.
That is to say, if we put this structure
on a piece of genetic
information where it's coded for
in a bacterium where we can turn off
RNase P when we want to,
and we can do that,
we show that when we turn this off
we make more of lacA.
When we allow P to function,
we make much less of lacA
because you get cleavage here
and degradation under these cases.
Now it was noticed in the '60s
when RNase P, ah excuse me,
when the lacZ operon was
being studied by many people
that there was a significant difference
between the translation or the production
of these three genes here.
In fact there was much less of lacA made
than lacY or lacZ.
And there was really no
explanations at all given for that.
I think in this case, with
the model system we have
actually supplied that explanation.
But this simply gives
you another indicator
of the range
and variety of substrates
for RNase P in bacteria.
So we can talk a little bit
about now in eukaryotes.
David Spector some time ago
published a paper in RNA,
I think it was 2000,
it was either early in 2010,
ah, yes it was.
And he asked us for samples
of RNase P from HeLa cells
which we sent to him.
He was looking at a substrate
that looked like this.
We don't have to worry about most of this.
This is just taken from his paper.
In fact, he was looking
at a very long piece
of messenger RNA
and inside the message he identified
what looked like a tRNA molecule here.
And as it turns out,
RNase P does cleave this molecule
right at the junction of the single
and double-stranded region here
and you wind up with this, okay.
This describes further
events in the pathway
which I'm not interested in
for our purposes at the moment.
But he clearly had found that RNase P
does cut in that particular position,
and he recently told
me that he has at least
one other such case of substrates
that look like this in eukaryotes.
So that's satisfying.
We already knew from previous
experiments of course
that RNase P cut tRNA precursors,
for example, in HeLa cells or mouse cells
or any other organism that
you wanted to look at.
We know that RNase P is
actually located in the nucleus
of Eukarya and I might
mention that a little later.
So it cleaves tRNA precursors.
It cleaves these long messages
with tRNAs in the middle of them.
We have evidence and we published evidence
that it cleaves ribosomal RNA precursors
in HeLa cells and in yeast.
It's hard to get purified
ribosomal precursors,
but the evidence we have
is pretty convincing.
So we have at least three classes
of substrates in eukaryotes
and I'm sure there are more substrates.
It's just that we haven't,
and I don't think anybody has
made the effort to look for more.
Now it had been suggested for some time
that in various organelles in eukaryotes,
for example, mitochondria,
or a chloroplast for example,
that there was no RNAse P of
the kind that I've mentioned.
It had been indicated
that there was RNAse P
that contained no RNA at all.
However a recent paper by
Koehler and Teitell in Cell
this year, a few months ago,
actually was quite a remarkable paper.
It was on the function of an enzyme,
polynucleotide phosphorylase, PNPase
which is responsible for importing
various pieces of RNA into mitochondria
in human cells.
And one of the things
it imports is RNase P.
And in fact, Teitell and
Koehler and their co-workers
showed that there were certain sequences
that actually were cleaved
by the conventional RNase P.
Now these diagrams are
taken from another paper,
but it doesn't really matter,
they demonstrate what I wanted to show.
And that is when you have
the classical RNase P
with an RNA subunit,
and in mitochondria you have situations
where you have a long piece of RNA
and interior in the RNA there
might be two tRNA sequences.
You have messenger RNA here,
messenger RNA here.
And in these kinds of
cases RNase P cuts it here
at the beginning of this tRNA,
and cuts it here at the
beginning of this tRNA.
It had been shown by people
who worked on these enzymes that
supposedly don't have
RNA associated with them
that if you have an RNA like this
at the head of a region where
there's a messenger RNA here
and you have one RNA here that
that these other enzymes
cleave this RNA at this particular point.
So that is a remarkable new finding.
I found that the whole
paper that I looked at
in this case was a very interesting paper
and very useful and it showed in fact
that RNase P seems to be,
in quotations, everywhere,
the classical RNase P.
There's one other thing
I'd like to show you
about the structure of the enzyme
and it's complicated.
It's essentially the crystal structure,
a fantastic crystal structure
performed by Mondragon and his colleagues
at Northwestern University.
They have made, they have done,
they have solved the crystal structure
of the ternary complex
which contains the RNA
subunit of RNase P from a
bacterium that's not too
different from E. coli,
the protein subunit of the complex,
the tRNA product of the complex,
and a single-strand piece of RNA
which supposedly would represent
the cleavage product
from a tRNA precursor.
So effectively we're looking
at the product of the reaction
with the product in the substrate.
This paper will be
published in Nature soon.
I can effectively guarantee that.
Okay, so this is a different
way of looking at it
from what the conventional picture is,
but here we have in blue or purple,
whatever you want to call it,
the RNase P RNA.
It's organized in this particular way.
Usually we turn at least by 90 degrees
and look at it from that point of view,
but that's all right.
And I'm not going to to into any
of the crystallographic
details at the moment.
I simply want to show that this is
what has been found and how it
confirms some of the predictions
that were earlier made.
This is a tRNA precursor here.
So this is the anticodon stem down here.
And this is the recognition site here
at the junction of the tRNA molecule.
And there would be a
single-stranded region
which we can't identify here.
The protein cofactor is
located in this region here.
Now there has been a lot
of RNA work done on this
before the crystal structure.
So we already knew something about
which parts of the RNA were
in contact with the protein.
We knew by cross-linking
studies which part of tRNA
were in contact with this
piece of the RNA too.
Nevertheless, I think this is
a fantastic piece of crystallography
and very interesting work.
So I offer my
congratulations to Mondragon.
We had shown
that the RNase P in
complex with the substrate
has different confirmations.
It can be the transient state
or the active state of the enzyme
and we don't know anything about that yet.
It could be the free substrate
or it could be the cleaved product
in the single-stranded region.
But we had shown from various
enzymological experiments
in vitro that these three sites,
these three confirmations must exist.
And Mondragon has succeeded in producing
the crystal structure of this one.
We had also shown
from cross-linking and other studies
that the aminocyl helix of
the substrate is denatured
during the cleavage product.
That is to say,
at the helical end of the tRNA precursor
where usually at the three-prime end
an amino acid is attached,
at the five-prime end you
have an extra substrate,
those strands come apart.
So it's no longer a double-stranded
region in the helix.
And we'd shown that that was the case.
And if you cross-link the
helix and it could not denature
then you got no enzymatic reaction at all.
And that was confirmed by
this particular structure.
It was shown by Mondragon
that in fact the two parts of this helix
are denatured in the complex.
And furthermore the
position of the protein
has been specified by various methods
and the crystal structure
confirmed all of that too.
So it's quite satisfying.
Okay.
I'm going to go on now to
some recent work in our lab
and I might skip some stuff
because I don't wanna go over time.
First of all,
here is the classical tRNA precursor.
It was from these molecules that in fact
we first deleted this region here,
this stem and loop and this stem and loop.
It was done with Bill MacLean
and we covalently linked this to this
and that was a very good substrate.
It was just one continuous
helix with a loop.
And then Tony Forster, a
postdoc from Australia,
this is 15 years ago at least
succeeded in deleting this loop here.
So we're just left with this strand
hydrogen bonded to this strand here.
And if you draw that differently,
this is what you see.
In fact these are now two
different RNA molecules,
but they get cleaved very well
by RNase P at this point here.
And they've been drawn
in different colors here,
because now they represent
the basis of the therapy
I'm going to talk about.
This can be any target RNA in a cell,
any cell.
And as long as you have
another piece of RNA
that can hydrogen bond to it here,
it's especially true of
bacteria in this case,
we call this external
guide sequence, the EGS.
And as long as this
can hydrogen bond here,
this is still a very good substrate.
It's just an imitation of model substrates
we made and it's cleaved by RNAse P.
Now,
if we have a piece of DNA
which is made into an
RNA or messenger RNA,
whatever you want,
and there's no external
guide sequence involved,
you make protein,
a regular state of affairs.
If you have an extra guide sequence,
external guide sequence,
hydrogen bonded to the piece of message
then cleavage is going to occur
at one particular end of the EGS
and you're gonna get mRNA cleavage there
by the host cell RNase P
which recognizes this as a substrate.
And you're going to
inactivate this particular RNA
and you're gonna stop it from
expressing itself completely.
So if the RNA's a viral RNA
or an RNA that codes for
a particular disease,
you're going to absolutely stop it
from functioning under those conditions.
So that's the basis of the therapy,
that you have this situation
and you have the RNase P
which exists inside the cell
and so you can do all these things.
Now these are some ways of
transporting any piece of RNA.
There are various other
mechanisms in which RNA's involved
and I'm not gonna talk
about them at the moment.
Let me just say that the
method I'm gonna describe
is just as good as siRNA.
We've tested siRNA on the same targets
as we've tested the EGS on
and the numbers are very comparable.
You can have things attached to antibodies
which themselves attach
to particular parts of cells.
You can have them attached
or inserted into viruses
which then infect cells.
You can have oligonucleotides
encompassed in liposomes
which are lipid bodies that
will wrap around a piece of RNA.
Or a nanoparticle containing some RNA.
Or you can have basic peptides
attached to pieces of RNA.
Although our previous work
had been done biologically,
that is to say, we made small genes
that coded for EGSes and
inserted them into bacteria
and they certainly work in E. coli
and some other organisms.
But now we're doing these experiments
with basic peptides with
morpholino oligonucleotides.
And I'll show you a picture
of that very shortly.
And this is just an
indication of the kinds of RNA
you could use to shut
down gene expression.
There are aptamers which
are small molecules
that bind to particular sequences.
So these are made out of RNA let us say.
Hammerhead ribozymes which
are not very good I think.
siRNA which can be used in
human cells for example.
Splicing variants which have been used
to attack certain diseases in which
there is a splicing variant
that causes diseases like
Duchenne muscular dystrophy
and you can adjust that splicing variants
back to the normal situation.
In a couple of papers
which have been published
you get some improvement
in the muscular dystrophy.
The EGS which is,
which is what I'm gonna talk about.
Locked nuclear RNA which
is another variant on RNA
and peptide nuclear RNA.
I'm not gonna talk much about these,
but they can be useful.
This is an old slide showing results
with our biological effects.
Simply that an E. coli for example,
we can inhibit the expression
of various of these genes.
When you induce beta-galactosidase
or alkaline phosphatase
they're made at a level of over 1,000 fold
of the constitutive level.
So normally they're hardly made at all,
but you can induce them
and then the level goes up.
With one EGS attacking
one site on the message,
you knock out 60% of the activity.
These are essential genes.
But this one is the one
that we're interested
in drug resistance.
And we're looking essentially
at chloramphenicol resistance.
And we can stop that,
we can reverse that into
chloramphenicol sensitivity
of a bacteria 100% by using
two EGSes that attack two different sites
in the messenger RNA that codes
for chloramphenicol resistance.
Okay, you can say that's all right,
but conventional antibiotics
are just as good.
Well, they're not just as good.
A one-step mutation can convert something
that's sensitive to drug resistance.
In our case, three mutations
as long as they're not right
next to each in the EGS
can still function.
So it's clear that that is a
much better biological result
than the conventional
method of doing things.
And this is also has been
replicated by somebody else
in actually California, now that I'm here,
on amikacin resistance.
Just let me go on now.
Very briefly I will say that we can now
isolate an EGS in a few hours
providing you have a supply
of E. coli RNase P on hand
which is very easy to arrange,
and a 1/2 ml solution
of a piece of random RNA.
So in our case we might have
something this long here
where N is the random RNA in these pieces
and we have various
restriction sites here,
and we just incubate this.
You can label the target RNA,
in any particular,
any particular RNA you want.
You can mix that labeled target RNA
with this random oligo here
and then incubate it for
15 minutes with RNAse P
and run it out on a gel.
It takes two hours perhaps.
Develop the film on the gel
and you will see immediately
whether or not you had any cleavage.
of the target RNA.
And in fact, we've shown this
prolifically over the last
couple years using this method.
We've identified EGSes in
many different bacteria
and they can be used for drug sensitivity
to target pathogenic
regions in pathogenic RNA.
It's a very convenient method.
Now let's get to this new method
which is the basic peptide's attached
to morpholino oligos.
This is a morpholino oligo.
We see the phosphate linkages
are not quite what you would expect.
There's a nitrogen in here.
This is a morpholino sugar in here,
a nitrogen in it.
But the bases appear
as they usually appear.
And the other aspect of using this
is that the morpholinos
are tremendously resistant
to nonspecific nucleases.
So you can incubate them with human serum
or bacterial growth medium
and they don't get degraded
for at least 24 hours,
probably much longer than that.
And that's why we use them.
Now you attach a basic peptide at one end.
And here it's 14
amino acid residues.
R is arginine.
X is 6-aminohexanoic acid.
So there are four repeats of this.
X again and then beta-alanine.
And this makes the covalent linkage
very powerful in terms
of penetrating bacteria.
We published this about a
year and a half ago or so.
Let me just say that if we have,
if we're looking at chloramphenicol
resistance in this case
and we're using two EGSes
which have been made
into morpholino oligos
with a basic peptide attached,
these are control
bacteria after four hours.
A scrambled oligo of the morpholino,
so it's almost as good as the control.
Two separate EGSes,
and two EGSes together.
So in this particular case,
we're down around
1/1000 of what we would've expected
for the control bacteria
which is actually a
very, very good number.
So that's at 50 micromolar.
When we do it with B. subtilis
inactivating the gyrA gene in B. subtilis,
we only need five micromolar of this.
And we're down to about,
in this case, only 0.2
of the viability of this.
If we do this at 15 micromolar,
we're down to about 1% of
the viability of the control.
So that works extremely well.
And let me just say in an experiment
that was finished a couple weeks
I'll just show some rough data.
We are now doing the experiment
with a different basic peptide.
It's a basic peptide that has
been isolated from human cells
that controls T cell regulation,
and it's 22 amino acids long.
It's written up here.
It is also very basic and we've
attached that to a morpholino oligo.
And this chloramphenicol resistance.
So we're down in the level between 1/1000
and a 1/10,000 viability.
Here, these are two
different preparations.
This preparation is obviously much better.
And that's what we're
working on at the moment.
This is at five micromolar
concentration
of the particular
compound that I worked on,
that I told you about.
So that's a summary of
some of our recent data.
I have some more data on some
molecular biological aspects
of the morpholino oligos
and how they interact
with sites in message,
but I'm not gonna show that to you
because it's getting late.
And I'll just show you
this one other experiment
which is an older summary of experiments
in eukaryotic cells.
I'm sure Fenyong will
recognize some of this.
I'm not gonna talk about
cerevisae right now,
but we can inhibit flu viruses
in mouse or canine cells
by attacking two different
genes in the flu virus.
Remember the flu virus has eight genes.
And it also has eight
pieces of RNA in its genome.
Each piece of RNA codes for a particular
one of its genes.
And by attacking both of
these particular genes
we essentially can
inactivate flu virus by 100%.
But I indicate 95% because there's
a 5% error in our methods.
These are essential proteins in E. coli,
in HeLa cells, I won't talk
about them more at the moment.
But Fenyong Liu has been
working for many years on
cytomegalovirus in mice and in humans.
Actually these are old data showing
that he can inhibit these
particular functions.
But I believe that he's
also been able to show the
inhibition of live animals
under these conditions.
And also herpes virus which he also did
in our lab a long time ago.
So I think this is a very
promising method to use,
and one that's certainly worth studying.
It is not necessarily
adding to our molecular
biological knowledge
of RNase P itself and what it's done.
But it shows that RNase P can
be used in very useful ways,
in this case, to attack
all kinds of disease.
And with that I shall leave you.
(audience applauds)
- [Audience Member] Sid,
I'm curious how the basic
peptide morpholino
penetrates into bacteria
so efficiently.
It's not the same kind of mechanism
that basic peptides like TAT
enter into mammalian cells.
It must be something different.
- I'm not sure it's very
different at all quite frankly.
- [Audience Member] The
TAT peptide penetrates
into mammalian cells by
first being internalized
into an endosome and from the endosome --
- Say the second half
of that sentence again.
- [Audience Member] The TAT peptide,
basic peptide, penetrates
into mammalian cells
by first being internalized
into an endosome.
- Okay.
- And then from there
into the cytoplasm, that's not happening.
- It's certainly not that, that's right.
- [Audience Member] I'm curious about
the toxicity and pharmacokinetics
of these molecules.
- I don't know anything the about it
because I haven't done any
experiments with live animals.
However,
there are people have done experiments
with these kinds of
compounds at AVI BioPharma
which is a company now
located outside of Seattle.
And they have cured infected
mice under these conditions,
and the mice don't suffer at all
under the conditions they used.
They just survive for
several weeks afterwards.
- [Audience Member] That's
encouraging, thanks.
- [Audience Member] When
you showed the cleavage
of some of the polycistronic
messenger RNAs in E. coli,
I assume that was an in vitro experiment.
- No, we've done it both ways.
- Because it was--
- For--
- [Audience Member] Pretty inefficient.
It was only a few percent
of the intact transcript
that was converted to product.
So how do you expect there--
- There are two different slides there.
One was of several different operons.
That was done in vivo, okay?
And then we did the lac operon
which was done in vitro and in vivo.
- [Audience Member] But
it's only a few percent
of the message even in vitro.
Is it more efficient than vivo,
the degree of cleavage
of the intact transcript?
The full-length transcript persisted.
You know 95% of it was still there after
you know more than an hour incubation.
- Well let me put it this way,
with the lac operon,
we completely destroy part
of the lac operon in vivo.
- Okay?
- So it's more--
- That was with a model system.
Now the other,
so I don't know what you
wanna say about that.
With the other operons it is true
that we don't have a good idea
of the quantitative result
of those experiments.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- [Audience Member] So
does the bacterial protein
stimulate the RNA of Archaea and so forth.
In other words,
if you combine the
different proteins and RNAs
are the proteins still active?
- Which protein?
- [Audience Member] The RNAse P protein.
So immediately, does the RNAse P protein
from E. coli for example,
stimulate the RNA
of RNAse P from Archaea and so forth?
- Well if you're talking about experiments
using an EGS to--
- [Audience Member] No,
no, this is going back
to the beginning of your talk.
- Well just under normal conditions?
- Yeah.
The amount of P protein for RNAse P,
there are about 400 to
500 copies in the cell.
And if you try and activate RNAse P
by attacking the message for the P protein
which we have done,
it actually takes
several more hours to kill those bacteria
than it does for example,
to just change chloramphenicol
resistance to sensitivity
because you have to deplete that reservoir
until you're down to maybe
20 molecules per cell
which is apparently not enough
to keep the molecules going.
- [Audience Member] EGS,
what needs to be done
to bring EGS as a therapeutic technology
in the--
- Somebody has to provide
a few million dollars
to set up a company to
investigate this for commercial purposes
and to build a reasonable system
for delivering the covalent linkage
of the basic peptide to the morpholino.
So I don't know anybody
with a few million dollars
who's willing to do that.
And I'm not a great entrepreneur,
so I can't do anything about it.
- [Audience Member] I
have a follow-up question.
Is it easier to design an EGS for viruses
as opposed to cancers?
- In concept and in principle, you could
for a virus, certainly for viruses.
And that's what Fenyong is doing.
- [Audience Member] Well, I wanna follow
was Stu's question.
How much we know about the biogenesis
of the enzyme in terms of the RNA subunit
and the protein subunit in E. coli?
- Just a minute, could you stand
a little bit further
back from the microphone?
Not that far back, okay.
- [Audience Member] So much
we know about the biogenesis
of the RNA and protein
subunits in E. coli?
I mean specifically when the bacteria grow
under different conditions
like under stress
or under rich medium.
Do we see any--
- For the protein?
- [Audience Member] As
well as the RNA subunit.
- Okay.
- Is there any regulation?
- The protein is made in an operon
with some ribosomal proteins in it.
Supposedly there is a binding,
the sequence of the
upstream part of that operon
has a binding site for the RNA subunits.
But we've done a number of experiments
in which we tried to regulate
the amount of RNA and
the protein in E. coli
and none of them have worked.
That is to say,
changing the amount of RNA
doesn't change the amount of protein.
Changing the amount of protein
doesn't change the amount of RNA.
That's about all I can say about that.
Is that what you wanted to know?
- [Audience Member] Because I'm wondering
whether the tRNA synthesis
is affected by that?
- Oh, that's a separate issue.
The RNA subunit is under
relaxed stringent control.
And I think so is the protein subunit.
So if you starve the cells for amino acids
or they go into stationary phase,
you stop making both the
RNA and the protein subunit.
- [Audience Member] Interesting.
- [Fenyong] Please join me
in thanking Professor Altman
for a wonderful lecture today.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
(bright music)